nous vous proposons à présent de faire
plus amples connaissances avec un
personnage de la chanson française on le
connaît surtout comme figurant
emblématique du groupe Les Garçons
Bouchers il s'appelle François Hadji
Lazaro et il fait aujourd'hui 15 ans de
carrière en sortant une compilation de
48 chansons reportages Pierre-Emmanuel
Luneau et Christophe Vignal
il n'a peut-être l'air de rien comme ça
de bon matin et pourtant François
Gillette Zaro est un esthète et comme un
esthète il s'est apprécié les bonnes
choses
un gros ermitage de Haribo va
entièrement fait de façon bio mais au
bon sens du terme
justement quand la troisième étage de
tuer le printemps déjà des vignes jaunes
qui durent pas longtemps pour voir vite
et qui sont hyper fruité super bon
cet artiste n'a pas fait que goûter au
plaisir de la bouche en vérité cet homme
est un boulimique de la vie
qu'est-ce que j'ai ce matin quel fruit
ton merde j'ai une pêche d'enfer
ça va le faire c'est la vie qui éclate
en 15 ans de carrière François a dit
Lazzaro ne s'est pas arrêté au simple
banjo dans son antre cacher quelque part
dans les hauteurs de Paris l'ogre
musicien a appris à jouer d'une
vingtaine d'instruments différents
cornemuse orgue de barbarie accordéon
guitare et même un exemplaire de la trop
méconnu d'ullsimère de violon évidemment
diverses et variés et puis du cimer
en Europe de l'Est et aussi dans les
Vosges c'est la famille de l'épinette
des Vosges qui en traversant
l'Atlantique en allant dans les
Appalaches s'est transformé en du cimer
au total depuis 1984 cet artiste hors
norme aura participé à 18 albums
aux côtés de Roland Topor ou des Garçons
Bouchers il aura donné quelques 900
concerts de par le monde
mais c'est au fond de cette cour
parisienne que François a dit Lazzaro
investit aussi beaucoup de son énergie
boucherie production est une maison de
disque à l'image de son créateur vaste
et coloré
il faut croire que ça plaît 150 albums
ont été produits les cassettes
continuent d'affluer alors ça dépend des
jours sur l'année donc c'est 1200 après
ça fait à peu près une moyenne de trois
par jour quoi et groupe véritable ils
ont les artistes véritables ils savent
plus trop signer donc nous reçois
énormément de choses ben non sur la même
du classique du jazz parce que les gens
savent plus aussi et compris même des
certaines références qui savent plus
trouver une maison de disque
[Musique]
depuis 15 ans qu'elle tourne entre
maison de disques et carrière solo la
petite entreprise de François gilladzaro
n'est pas prête de s'arrêter
[Musique]